[Musik]
meine erste reise in die antarktis das
erste mal dass ich an einer expedition
teilnehmen kann
ja das wollte man eine zweite expedition
in die antarktis sein und ich bin total
gespannt wie das im vergleich zu der
ersten expedition sein wird auf der
reise dabei haben wir so genannte salz
und licht haben mit denen man das
entstehen und das schmelzen von
eisschollen messen kann es geht um mehr
als untersuchung und ich bin sehr
gespannt was uns erwartet
zum einen ist es natürlich sehr kalt
dann sind wir eben auf offenen auf dem
offenen meer unterwegs auf dem
forschungsschiff polarstern und ich bin
gespannt wie es ist unter solchen
bedingungen zu forschen
als mathematikerin will ich es natürlich
gewohnt er mit papier und bleistift zu
arbeiten
theorien herzuleiten formel herzuleiten
oder mit numerischen
computersimulationen zu arbeiten
in meinem mathematik studium hätte ich
das nicht erwartet dass ich irgendwann
in der antrag zu stehen werde
und insofern ist das für mich etwas ganz
besonderes so sein hands on in der
antrag des selbst daten zu erheben und
einen ganz kleinen beitrag dazu machen
dass diese großen datenmengen die wir
sonst immer in unseren modellen benutzen
auch wirklich zustande kommen das erste
mal dass ich gerne nackt ist bin ich
freue mich total darauf dann tatsächlich
mal
dem eis dort stiegen zu können sonst
besonders interessiert ist sozusagen das
leben und sterben der eisschollen also
was wir messen wollen ist letztendlich
wie sich die temperatur die sanität und
auch die eisdicke über die zeit
verändern und wir werden versuchen mit
sogenannten salz und licht hafen die neu
entwickelt wurden zum ersten mal
aufzuzeichnen wie wirklich die schulen
wachsen und auch wieder schmelzen